[Music]
so first of all let's just go on the
classics
the original series tng d space nine
voyager all those what is your
favorite star trek series
and and why
do you have a favorite
uh my favorite is definitely a deep
space nine um
there's a bunch of reasons for one thing
it was uh it went against uh character
essentially for uh star trek series it
was dark it was messy it showed the
undercarriage of uh the
federation uh i think it was one of the
best series on television regardless of
sci-fi or whatever the genre was of a
father-son relationship
yeah
and that i and especially in the black
communities you see
if you hear it from their perspective
their point of view it's like
we've never seen that before
i think my favorite though is is the
next generation
but because that was the show that was
it's like my star trek i watched the
original series when i was little when i
was tiny little boy
um but i you know it was it was
already 30 years old when i was watching
it you know so it was really quite dated
um
and then but then the t and t and g came
along the next generation and i was
watching them new every week and i'd
never seen it before so the brand new
series was coming out i was having to
like wait for it we can you know um and
then episodes like
um
best of both worlds blew my
mind i mean it at the time in
1987 when it started it went where uh no
tv series went before you know i
actually put this question out on
facebook a lot and stuff and and some
people did just their answers i said
what's the best star trek and some
people's answer was star trek
it's all
brilliant great and i'm like yeah but
not all star trek is equal it just isn't
um
if i was guess ask you then a phaser
against your head what is the best star
trek series
though would it be deep 69 still is that
why it's your favorite because it's just
the best of the genre
um i think it's the best of the genre
but um
i'm telling you dude
lower decks
is just
oh yeah that's controversial oh there'll
be comments oh there's yeah you're going
to get all the hate mail man but i
really love lower decks i mean it is
just so wrong i mean
in so many ways for all the right
reasons almost now talk about going
against your standard um
trek flavor
lower decks i mean you know you have the
the the functional dysfunctionals in the
in the bowels of the cerrito
running around with their panic attacks
lower decks i will say to you i love
lodex i think it's brilliant because i
think it's um
but i don't really consider it star trek
it's not canon
it isn't canon the stuff that goes on in
that series you know
and
more importantly though
to me it's like it's a love letter to
the next generation
i think it is yeah yeah it's not really
um it's not really star trek in like the
the strictest sense of the word when i
turn on paramount plus here in the us
you know um
if i have right now my choices are
prodigy
uh lower decks or the new uh uh
discovery uh
or season four episode
i started off with uh lower decks
because like what in the hell are they
gonna do this week all right
my my favorite if i'm gonna say my
favorite series is tng if we go back to
proper star trek right but i honestly
think i'm with you the best series of
star trek is deep space nine and it's
that gets a lot of it doesn't get a lot
of love sometimes deep space nine
um but i'm with you i think it broke the
mould of what star trek was right you
get episodes
we'll go talk about the series in
specifics but um in the pale moonlight
with cisco
broke the wall down and cisco was
talking about this plan that they've had
to drag that to get the romulans
involved in the um dominion war and it
really showed it to the dark side not
only of cisco but of the federation
um and i don't think i'd ever seen it
like tng
touched on this occasion there's a
couple of episodes where you know you
see the dark side of the the the
federation
um
but not really you know that the pegasus
episode a couple of others
um but in this it really we know we saw
what people are actually capable of when
we're threatened and when we're you know
we're back's against the wall sort of
thing and and what humanity's capable of
and it was i don't know it's more
realistic
than than maybe tng where's that you
know there was this utopia the golden
age of the federation and and everything
else and everything was all lovely and
fuzzy
you know
whereas this thing got a bit grittier
you know like you know
cisco is you know the real problem with
the federation is earth
you know because the on earth is a
paradise no one's hungry there's no
homelessness and everything but out here
you know at the ass in the federation
space
it's not earth so i put a poll on
last week here we go we got 213 votes
and but the question was what is the
best star trek and then what really
inspired us to do this video was
actually after i've been up two or three
days d space nine was way ahead
i mean it was like it was d600 was like
40 of the votes or something but i mean
obviously obviously more votes came in
and it's evened out a little bit
and um so i'll give you the numbers the
original series 18 the next generation
was the winner with 36 just over a third
of the votes four year just 16
deep space nine 21.9 uh 21 which i
thought was really interesting an
enterprise nine percent
is there anything that really surprises
you with those with those numbers yeah
you know it's um
a regeneration has a track i mean
there's you know there's so much
material out there oh if you throw in
the books and comic books i mean there's
literally there's some but something for
damn near everybody to fan over you know
um
i mean that's why i love the tng so
exactly that's my star trek that was
this trick when i was like 15 16 but you
know so that's mine right
and i think it's just a wealth of
material and deep storytelling is uh
i think that's what has such a broad
audience is there's something for
everybody you know you know
depending on what kind of story style
you want you know
you may be i mean you may have kids that
are just you know
neck deep in prodigy
because it tells a wholly different side
of the story
can't talk about prodigy because we
haven't got it in the uk yet we're not
allowed it
no we have prodigy and tea
what does that tell you
yeah the americans are spoiled
[Music]